This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When the Statue of Liberty was dedicated in 1886, it was a dull copper color. The whole statue is covered with a layer of copper metal about the thickness of two pennies. But after about 1900, the physical processes that govern the known universe began to take their toll, and the copper skin oxidized into a greenish patina that can be seen on the statue to this day. When the statue underwent a massive restoration in the 1980s, the head and shoulder were realigned, the point on the crown that had been digging into her arm for a century was shortened the defects in the internal skeleton were thoroughly addressed, and of course, the weather beaten exterior was cleaned, but there
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。1886年自由女神像落成时，它呈现出暗淡的铜色。整座雕像覆盖着一层厚度约为两枚硬币的铜金属。但在1900年左右，支配已知宇宙的物理过程开始产生影响，铜皮氧化成了绿色的铜绿，这种颜色至今仍能在雕像上看到。当雕像在20世纪80年代进行大规模修复时，头部和肩部被重新校准，皇冠上一个戳了她手臂一个世纪的尖角被缩短了，内部骨架的缺陷得到了彻底解决，当然，饱经风霜的外表也被清理干净了，但是
was no notion that the statue's skin should be returned to the dull copper color she was born with. But if they had shined up Lady Liberty to her original copper color, the people of New York City. Probably would have reacted like this. I don't like looking at it. This is not someone from New York, as you can probably guess. That's Barbara Clark, five generations of her family have lived in Sterling, Scotland. My name's Barbara Clark, and I've lived in Sterling all my life apart from when I was
当时并没有人认为应该把雕像的皮肤恢复成她诞生时那种暗淡的铜色。但如果他们把自由女神像擦亮成最初的铜色，纽约市民大概会是这种反应：“我不喜欢看它。”正如你可能猜到的，这不是纽约人。那是芭芭拉·克拉克，她的家族五代人都住在苏格兰的斯特灵。我叫芭芭拉·克拉克，除了上大学的时候，我这辈子都住在斯特灵。
at university. Sterling is also the home of Sterling, a truly marvelous place that I just love to visit that sits atop a giant cragg or hill overlooking the whole town of Stirling. Some castle has been there since the 12th century and maybe before, but the current buildings date from the 15th and 16th centuries. Well, obviously it's part of our lives. We see it every single day and as children we plead in it, we ran all around it.
斯特灵也是斯特灵城堡的所在地，那是一个我非常喜欢去参观的绝妙地方，它坐落在一座巨大的岩石或山丘之上，俯瞰着整个斯特灵镇。自12世纪甚至更早以来，那里就一直有城堡，但目前的建筑可以追溯到15世纪和16世纪。嗯，显然它是我们生活的一部分。我们每天都能看到它，小时候我们在里面玩耍，在它周围奔跑。
When we think of medieval castles, we usually picture a grand structure with subdued, dark stone masonry. But when you gaze upon Sterling Castle today from the town below, you will notice that one of the buildings is different from the others. Since 1999, after a long restoration effort, the Great Hall of Sterling Castle has been bright yellow. This bright yellow building, you know, sticking out like a sore thumb, and people were just horrified. I can remember just thinking, this is a nightmare.
当我们想到中世纪城堡时，通常会想象出一座带有柔和、深色石砌建筑的宏伟结构。但当你今天从下方的城镇凝视斯特灵城堡时，你会注意到其中一座建筑与众不同。自1999年经过长期的修复工作后，斯特灵城堡的大厅变成了亮黄色。这座亮黄色的建筑，你知道，显得格格不入，人们感到非常震惊。我记得当时心想，这简直是一场噩梦。
The story of how the great hall of Stirling Castle came to be painted bright yellow illustrates the unexpected complexity in the art of restoration. It comes down to this question, when you choose to restore something, which moment in time are you restoring it to? Some kind of nameless group of people reached that decision and I don't question their motives, but I question their understanding of the effect that it was going to have on people's feelings towards the castle. Who made that decision?
斯特灵城堡大厅被漆成亮黄色的故事，说明了修复艺术中意想不到的复杂性。这归结为一个问题：当你选择修复某样东西时，你是要把它恢复到哪个时间点？某种不知名的群体做出了那个决定，我不怀疑他们的动机，但我怀疑他们是否理解这会对人们对城堡的感情产生什么影响。是谁做出了那个决定？
Oh, I know. It was this guy. My name is Peter Buchanan. I work with Historic Scotland. My title now is Project Manager. I joined Historic Scotland in 1991 to work on the Stern and Castle project. Historic Scotland is the government organization charged with educating the public and safeguarding Scotland's historic treasures. They took over the care of Sterling Castle and started the Great Hall Restoration in 1991. First, let's get some Castle facts straight. The Castle and a lot of people have this very tailed Disneyland thing in their heads where it's all one huge building with turrets. Most medieval castles were a collection of buildings for certain things. They had a chapel, that a palace, they would have had kitchens. The Great Hall is one of those key buildings in a castle, and to quote Bill Bryson in his book
哦，我知道。是这个人。我叫彼得·布坎南。我在苏格兰历史环境局工作。我现在的工作头衔是项目经理。我于1991年加入苏格兰历史环境局，负责斯特灵城堡项目。苏格兰历史环境局是负责教育公众和保护苏格兰历史宝藏的政府机构。他们接管了斯特灵城堡，并于1991年开始了大厅的修复工作。首先，让我们弄清楚一些关于城堡的事实。很多人脑子里对城堡有一种非常迪士尼式的刻板印象，认为它是一整座带有塔楼的巨大建筑。大多数中世纪城堡是用于特定用途的建筑群。它们有礼拜堂、宫殿、厨房。大厅是城堡中那些关键建筑之一，引用比尔·布莱森在他的书
At Home, no room has fallen further in history than the hall. Now a place to wipe feet and hang hats, once it was the most important room in the house. It is a huge gathering space and the one here at Stirling was also for the Parliament of Scotland. So the kings sat here, they would set laws, they would have banquets and feasts, they would entertain lavishly. When Peter Buchanan adopted the great hall of Stirling, it was in an awful state. So Stirling Castle up until 1964 was a military garrison. From 1800 to 1964, the castle was owned by the war office, and they did not treat the castle as a historic artifact to be preserved. Most of the buildings within the castle were used by them.
《居家》中的话，历史上没有哪个房间比大厅地位下降得更厉害了。现在它只是一个擦脚和挂帽子的地方，但曾经它是房子里最重要的房间。它是一个巨大的聚会空间，而斯特灵的这个大厅也是苏格兰议会的所在地。所以国王们坐在这里，他们会制定法律，举行宴会和盛宴，进行奢华的招待。当彼得·布坎南接手斯特灵大厅时，它处于一种糟糕的状态。斯特灵城堡直到1964年一直是一个军事驻地。从1800年到1964年，城堡归战争办公室所有，他们并没有把城堡当作需要保护的历史文物来对待。城堡内的大多数建筑都被他们使用了。
The great hall was used as barricade accommodation. Turning the one big fancy room into barracks meant adding floors, altering windows, replacing the ceiling, really changing everything. Once the military left, the place was gutted. And when Peter's team took over in 1991, the building was a shelf. It still had a military roof on it,
大厅被用作营房住宿。把那个宽敞华丽的房间变成营房意味着增加楼层、改变窗户、更换天花板，真正改变了一切。军队离开后，这个地方被掏空了。当彼得的团队在1991年接手时，这座建筑只剩下一个空壳。它仍然保留着一个军事屋顶，
but it was left with a huge question mark as to what we should do with it. The typical mandate of Historic Scotland is to preserve historic places in the state they were found. But the great hall of Stirling Castle required some drastic measures. So what state do you restore it to? Do you preference the military period
但对于我们应该拿它怎么办，留下了一个巨大的问号。苏格兰历史环境局的典型使命是保护历史遗迹的原貌。但斯特灵城堡的大厅需要采取一些激进的措施。那么你把它恢复到什么状态呢？你是优先考虑军事时期
from the 1800s or the medieval and Renaissance period? Strategically, the castle had been important for hundreds of years. Stirling's role in the history of Scotland has been sent to us since practically the earliest times of the first recorded kings. Castle Hill overlooks a bog on one side and the bridge over the fourth river on the other. So for hundreds of years it was the place that controlled trade for the whole region. Mary Queen of Scots was crowned there.
还是中世纪和文艺复兴时期？从战略上讲，这座城堡几百年来一直很重要。斯特灵在苏格兰历史中的作用，几乎从最早的记录国王时代起就一直如此。城堡山一边俯瞰着沼泽，另一边俯瞰着福斯河上的桥梁。因此，几百年来，它一直是控制整个地区贸易的地方。苏格兰女王玛丽就是在那里加冕的。
And it was seen that the cultural significance of these things aren't weighed the significance of the military period. Using this logic they decided to restore the Great Hall to a state it was about three to four hundred years in the past. But that kind of restoration is not simple. First of all the records aren't all that consistent. Now, the series of etchings of the Great Hall. Unfortunately, they all show slightly different things. Traditionally, you have ridge beasts, heraldic beasts on the top of the Great Hall.
人们认为这些事物的文化意义超过了军事时期的意义。基于这种逻辑，他们决定将大厅恢复到三四百年前的状态。但这种修复并不简单。首先，记录并不完全一致。现在，有一系列关于大厅的蚀刻画。不幸的是，它们显示的细节略有不同。传统上，大厅顶部有脊兽，即纹章兽。
These are big stone statues of unicorns and lions that sit on the apex of the roof. All of our etchings show these, but they show different numbers of them. So the etchings, they're great to give a kind of an idea of what the cast might have looked like, but as a tool for restoration, they weren't much use. To help figure out where the Ridge Bees should be placed on top of the building, they had to figure out the original structure of the roof. Sometimes in the 20th century, the roof had been completely replaced by the military. But the original hall of the roof. Sometime in the 20th century, the roof had been completely replaced by the military, but the original hall had this glorious Hammer Beam roof. A Hammer Beam roof is a medieval technique that uses wood beams as a network of cantilevers
这些是坐在屋顶顶端的独角兽和狮子的大型石雕。我们所有的蚀刻画都显示了这些，但它们的数量各不相同。所以，这些蚀刻画对于了解城堡可能的样子很有帮助，但作为修复工具，它们没什么用。为了弄清楚脊兽应该放在建筑顶部的什么位置，他们必须弄清楚屋顶的原始结构。20世纪的某个时候，屋顶被军队完全更换了。但原始大厅的屋顶。20世纪的某个时候，屋顶被军队完全更换了，但原始大厅有这种辉煌的锤梁屋顶。锤梁屋顶是一种中世纪技术，它使用木梁作为悬臂网络
and trusses on the inside to make the roof strong over such a big wide open room. You can see all the timber when you look up from inside the hall, it's stunning. It's a jigsaw puzzle of beautiful triangles that are amazing to behold. Triangles are the best. Because the ridge beasts weighed three-quarters of a ton, they could only be placed where the hammer beam roof was the strongest. This is as true now as it was 300 years ago. We've got a hammer beam roof to construct, and we've got no hammer beam roof left. We want to get it right, but we need clues to be able to do that. They found one diagram, a cross section of the hammer beam roof of the Great Hall from
和内部桁架，使屋顶在如此宽敞的房间上方保持坚固。当你从大厅内部向上看时，你可以看到所有的木材，非常壮观。它是一个美丽的三角形拼图，令人惊叹。三角形是最好的。因为脊兽重达四分之三吨，它们只能放置在锤梁屋顶最坚固的地方。这在今天和300年前一样适用。我们要建造一个锤梁屋顶，但我们没有任何现成的锤梁屋顶。我们想把它做好，但我们需要线索才能做到这一点。他们找到了一张图表，是大厅锤梁屋顶的横截面，来自
1719. But since it's the only record, it's hard to know if it's completely accurate. Since there was no other information about what the roof looked like, they began researching the surveyors from 1719 who drew the diagram and they found that other diagrams they drew of other castles were very accurate. So here's our leap of faith. This is where you start to have to use conjecture in your restoration to make value judgments and we've decided that we will put the whole of the structure back. So this is what we're basing it on. So using that one historic document,
1719年。但由于它是唯一的记录，很难知道它是否完全准确。由于没有关于屋顶样子的其他信息，他们开始研究1719年绘制该图表的测量员，发现他们绘制的其他城堡的图表非常准确。所以这是我们的一次信念飞跃。这就是你开始在修复过程中不得不使用推测来做出价值判断的地方，我们决定我们将把整个结构恢复原样。所以这就是我们的依据。因此，利用那一份历史文件，
they reconstructed the roof, which determined where the heavy stone ridge beasts would be placed on top. One discovery gets another and another, and the original building comes into focus, and that's the detective work of restoration. Careful research, discovery, verification, sometimes conjecture, leaps of faith,
他们重建了屋顶，这决定了沉重的石制脊兽将放置在顶部的什么位置。一个发现引出另一个，原始建筑逐渐清晰起来，这就是修复工作的侦探工作。仔细的研究、发现、验证，有时是推测，信念的飞跃，
it's this beautiful amalgam of history, science, verification, sometimes conjecture, leaps of faith, it's this beautiful amalgam of history, science and art. The Hammerbeam roof was completed in 1999 and everyone who sees it, including the sterling folk, seemed to agree, it looks really great. So far, no controversy. But as we know, the roof was not the only thing to change, so the controversy is coming. the roof was not the only thing to change, so the controversy is coming. The building, when we'd taken it over in 1991, was almost completely grey stone. There was none of the original finishes left, but in one corner, just under the West Bay, there had been a little lean-to-shelter built in front of a door. And when we took it away, we found a complete panel of the original lime wash.
这是历史、科学、验证的完美结合，有时是推测，信念的飞跃，这是历史、科学和艺术的完美结合。锤梁屋顶于1999年完工，每个看到它的人，包括斯特灵当地人，似乎都同意，它看起来真的很棒。到目前为止，没有争议。但我们知道，屋顶并不是唯一改变的东西，所以争议即将到来。屋顶并不是唯一改变的东西，所以争议即将到来。1991年我们接手时，这座建筑几乎全是灰色的石头。没有任何原始饰面残留，但在一个角落，就在西湾下方，门前建了一个小棚子。当我们把它拆掉时，我们发现了一块完整的原始石灰涂层。
Lime wash is pure lime meaning calcium oxide not the green citrus fruit and it also contains earth-based pigments. It's a coating that's meant to protect the stone masonry. In the case of sterling they found a significant yellow ochre layer of lime wash. The bright yellow was very intentional. Hundreds of years ago the built world was basically brown, but on this giant hill there was this great yellow piece of ostentatious bling that signaled for miles that this was a place for a king. And we did huge sample panels of the line rushes all around the building to show people what it might have looked like and what the Cutters might have been. And we brought a lot of people from the starting area to see this as well because what we were intending to do based on the analysis and the information we had
石灰涂层是纯石灰，意思是氧化钙，而不是那种绿色的柑橘类水果，它还含有土基颜料。这是一种旨在保护石砌建筑的涂层。在斯特灵的案例中，他们发现了一层明显的黄色赭石石灰涂层。亮黄色是非常刻意的。几百年前，建筑世界基本上是棕色的，但在这座巨大的山丘上，有这块巨大的、炫耀的黄色装饰，几英里外就能发出信号，表明这是一个国王居住的地方。我们在建筑周围做了巨大的石灰涂层样本板，向人们展示它可能的样子，以及颜色可能是什么。我们也带了很多斯特灵地区的人来看这些，因为基于我们拥有的分析和信息，我们打算做的是
was to put the finishes back. And that is exactly what they did, which is why the great hall is yellow, which did not exactly go over well with the people of sterile. Strangely in restoration terms, it's the one element that we had the most evidence for. They actually had physical pieces of the exterior lime wash all over the castle. The hammer beam roof on the other hand was based much more on conjecture. But everyone loves the hammer beam roof. When Peter's team was putting on the yellow finish, the great hall was completely covered and scaffolding and plastic. This may have contributed to the intensity of the reaction from
把饰面恢复原样。而这正是他们所做的，这就是为什么大厅是黄色的，这在斯特灵人民中并不太受欢迎。奇怪的是，在修复术语中，这是我们证据最充分的一个元素。他们实际上在城堡各处都有原始石灰涂层的实物碎片。另一方面，锤梁屋顶更多是基于推测。但每个人都喜欢锤梁屋顶。当彼得的团队正在涂上黄色饰面时，大厅被脚手架和塑料完全覆盖了。这可能加剧了
the locals once it was unveiled. Here's Sterling resident Barbara Clark again. The entire hall was shrouded in tarpollin for about ten years. And nobody knew really what was going on. We knew there were lots of stone masons up there, but nobody knew anything about anything else. So when the Great Anvailing came, it was a total surprise. It just looked so awful. And to this day, I don't like it. When I asked Peter Buchanan what he would have done differently if he had to do it all over again, he says he would do all the same restorations, but he would have been more aggressive about outreach.
当地人在它揭幕后的强烈反应。这是斯特灵居民芭芭拉·克拉克。整个大厅被防水布覆盖了大约十年。没人真正知道发生了什么。我们知道上面有很多石匠，但没人知道其他任何事情。所以当大揭幕时，这完全是一个惊喜。它看起来太糟糕了。直到今天，我还是不喜欢它。当我问彼得·布坎南如果一切重来，他会做些什么不同的事情时，他说他会做同样的修复工作，但他会更积极地进行外联。
We could have tried harder. We set up for a couple of weekends down in the centre of Stirling to explain what we were doing. We had lots of groups and lots of people around to see the samples before we went any further. But really getting that message out through the media and getting to people to understand it is very, very difficult. And when it is a change on the scale, I think that possibly a bigger marketing campaign should have gone out there. This was 15 years ago before Twitter and Facebook made it easier to reach people. Certainly we've learnt the experience from the great hall as to how we should be getting messages out.
我们本可以更努力一些。我们在斯特灵市中心设立了几个周末来解释我们在做什么。在进一步行动之前，我们有很多团体和很多人来看样本。但真正通过媒体传达那个信息并让人们理解它是非常非常困难的。当它是这种规模的改变时，我认为可能应该进行更大规模的营销活动。那是15年前，在Twitter和Facebook让接触人们变得更容易之前。当然，我们从大厅的经历中吸取了教训，了解了我们应该如何传达信息。
If people really understand what you're doing and really buy into it from day one, then I think it makes it a lot easier to be accepted. All restorations are unique. I don't think the Statue of Liberty should have been returned to copper when it was restored. As a landmark, people fell in love with it and it gained its significance when it was green. It made sense to keep it that way. But I found being in the bright yellow-great-haul at Sterling Castle really exciting.
如果人们真正理解你在做什么，并从第一天起就真正认同它，那么我认为这会让它更容易被接受。所有的修复都是独一无二的。我不认为自由女神像在修复时应该恢复成铜色。作为一个地标，人们爱上了它，它在变成绿色时获得了它的意义。保持这种状态是有道理的。但我发现身处斯特灵城堡亮黄色的大厅里真的很令人兴奋。
I'm sympathetic to the fact that the color was shocking to the residents who grew up with it looking completely different, but its brightness brought it to life for me, and made me reinterpret my faded and ultimately wrong image of the past. It's now assumed that nearly all the Greek and Roman sculptures that we know in love were painted bright vibrant colors, even though most of us can only imagine them as white marble. When I see color reconstructions of ancient statues, I think they look ridiculous. But I can't help but feel that I know the Greeks and Romans a little bit better after
我同情那些从小看着它完全不同样子的居民，这种颜色对他们来说很震惊，但它的明亮对我来说让它栩栩如生，并让我重新诠释了我对过去那种褪色且最终错误的印象。现在人们认为我们所知和喜爱的几乎所有希腊和罗马雕塑都被涂上了明亮鲜艳的颜色，尽管我们大多数人只能想象它们是白色大理石。当我看到古代雕像的彩色重建图时，我觉得它们看起来很荒谬。但我忍不住觉得，在
seeing what they thought looked good. I feel the same about the Renaissance artisans who designed the color schemes inside and outside sterling castle. They were mixing colors that really didn't match. They were using them in extraordinary ways. They were having great film and showing an awful lot of wealth and power in the process. But this is probably the first and last such restoration for Historic Scotland. New scanning and 3D rendering technology means that you can quote unquote the store a place and teach people what it looked like
看到他们认为好看的东西后，我更了解希腊人和罗马人了。我对设计斯特灵城堡内外配色方案的文艺复兴时期的工匠也有同样的感觉。他们混合的颜色真的不匹配。他们以非凡的方式使用它们。他们玩得很开心，并在过程中展示了大量的财富和权力。但这可能是苏格兰历史环境局第一次也是最后一次这样的修复。新的扫描和3D渲染技术意味着你可以“引用”修复一个地方，并教人们它在历史上的任何时候是什么样子
at any point in history inside the virtual world of a computer exhibit without doing anything drastic to the actual physical structure at all. And to be honest, I'm much happier with that approach. We can do extraordinary things now through technology that we couldn't have done 15 years ago. And it's a really, really easy way to educate people
在计算机虚拟世界的展览中，而根本不需要对实际的物理结构做任何激进的事情。老实说，我对那种方法更满意。我们现在可以通过技术做一些15年前无法做到的非凡事情。这是一种非常非常简单的教育人们的方式，
to show them what things might have been like without being too heavy-handed to the monument. So I suspect the Great Hall will remain as a unique restoration of the Historic Scotland's history. Which totally makes sense. But every once in a while, it's nice to be bold and daring like our ancestors were, and slap on that bright coat of paint, and see just how vivid the world once was.
向他们展示事物可能的样子，而不会对古迹采取过于强硬的手段。所以我怀疑大厅将保持为苏格兰历史环境局历史上的一次独特修复。这完全说得通。但偶尔，像我们的祖先一样大胆和勇敢，涂上那层明亮的油漆，看看世界曾经是多么生动，也是一件好事。
So I spent a whole weekend sterling, and while I was there, my friends Helen Zoltzman and Martin Oswig came up to visit from London. Helen and Martin work on the great podcast Answer Me This Together, which is one of my absolute favorites. It's one tons of awards and it's incredibly popular in the UK. And when we started Reotopia, I talked with Helen about the idea of her doing a new show specifically for us on whatever she wanted. Helen is a language and etymology fanatic,
所以我花了一个周末在斯特灵，当我在那里时，我的朋友海伦·佐尔茨曼和马丁·奥斯威格从伦敦来看我。海伦和马丁制作了很棒的播客《回答我这个》，这是我的绝对最爱之一。它赢得了无数奖项，在英国非常受欢迎。当我们开始《重塑乌托邦》时，我和海伦谈到了她专门为我们制作一个新节目的想法，内容随她喜欢。海伦是一个语言和词源狂热者，
and she pitched us the illusionist, which I'm going to describe as 99% invisible for words. Mainly so everyone who listens to this show will understand that if you love 99% invisible, you'll love the illusionist. You can find out more and subscribe at the allusionist.org. That's allusionist with an A, but as a little summertime treat I thought I'd just play for you the latest episode of The Allusionist by Helen's
她向我们推销了《典故学家》，我将其描述为“文字版的《99%隐形》”。主要是为了让所有听这个节目的人都能明白，如果你喜欢《99%隐形》，你就会喜欢《典故学家》。你可以在allusionist.org了解更多并订阅。那是带A的Allusionist，但作为一个小小的夏日款待，我想为你播放海伦的最新一集《典故学家》
Ultimate. Welcome to The Allusionist, in which I, Helen's Ultraman's, Woptulcalve are five magic linguistic beings. Coming up in the show, word games. To prepare yourself for which here's a game word, game as in the genre of meat is so called because it was obtained through the game or sport of hunting.
终极版。欢迎来到《典故学家》，在节目中，我，海伦·佐尔茨曼，是五个神奇的语言存在。节目即将开始，文字游戏。为了准备，这里有一个游戏词，游戏作为肉类的一种类型，之所以这样称呼，是因为它是通过狩猎的游戏或运动获得的。
And this history looks in venison, which evolved from the Latin verb venare, meaning to hunt, and came through English through the old French venison, which meant the meat of a large game animal, usually deer or wild boar. the Nari meaning to hunt, and came through English through the old French Venosule, which meant the meat of a large game animal, usually deer or wild boar, and that's the clearest to why the animal is called a deer until the point at which it's being eaten, where upon it becomes venison. The same with pairings like cow and beef and pig and pork and sheep and mutton, the words for the creatures in their living state are the Anglo-Saxon ones,
这段历史看起来像鹿肉，它源自拉丁语动词venare，意思是狩猎，并通过古法语venison进入英语，意思是大型猎物的肉，通常是鹿或野猪。nari意思是狩猎，并通过古法语Venosule进入英语，意思是大型猎物的肉，通常是鹿或野猪，这就是为什么动物被称为鹿，直到它被吃掉的那一刻，它就变成了鹿肉。像牛和牛肉、猪和猪肉、羊和羊肉这样的配对也是如此，生物在活着状态下的词是盎格鲁-撒克逊词，
whereas the meat words originated from French. After the Norman invasion of Britain in 1066, there came a few hundred years in which the aristocracy was speaking French, and they were the ones who could afford to eat the meat. And also, they were usually the ones whose words were being recorded in writing for posterity. So there you go, meat words, on with the show. Gather round children, Grandmas got a story about how we had to make our own fun on long-boring journeys before we had iPads, or indeed any equipment at all beyond the capitol, because who hasn't had to while away hours stuck in a car or on a box or a train playing Word Games. Such fun!
而肉类词汇起源于法语。1066年诺曼征服英国后，有几百年时间贵族们说法语，他们是那些买得起肉的人。而且，他们通常是那些词汇被记录在案以供后世参考的人。所以就这样，肉类词汇，节目继续。孩子们围过来，奶奶有个故事，讲的是在我们有iPad之前，或者除了资本之外没有任何设备，我们是如何在漫长无聊的旅程中自己找乐子的，因为谁没有在车里、公共汽车或火车上花上几个小时玩文字游戏呢？真有趣！
I spy where you're listing boring things, or the Ministers cat where you're listing adjectives. The number plate game where you have to name things that start with the same letters as you can see on the number plate of the car you've been stuck behind in a traffic jam forever, or replacing words in songs with rude words, or the old family favourite. Guess how many words you can say before the driver shouts at you to shut up, and you have to sit in silence for two hours. Bonus points if you got beyond four. Here's my issue with these games. None of them are actually much fun to play, except for the replacing words in a song with rude words game, which is still pretty good. But really most of these word games are, but
“我看见”是你列举无聊的东西，或者“牧师的猫”是你列举形容词。车牌游戏，你必须命名那些以你在交通堵塞中永远被困在后面的车牌上看到的相同字母开头的东西，或者用粗俗的词替换歌曲中的词，或者旧的家庭最爱。猜猜在司机对你大喊闭嘴之前你能说多少个词，然后你必须沉默两个小时。如果你超过四个，有额外加分。这就是我对这些游戏的看法。它们实际上玩起来都不太有趣，除了用粗俗的词替换歌曲中的词的游戏，这仍然相当不错。但实际上大多数这些文字游戏是，但
was fun as filling in a spreadsheet. They do fulfill the function of obliterating an awkward silence without everyone having to think of conversational topics, but the prize isn't so much winning the game as the journey being over so you don't have to play the game anymore. Also words are all over the place and on the average day you'll be deploying or taking in many thousands. So how do you take these things which are ubiquitous and can cocked fun out of them? What are the elements of a top-notch word game? A bit of viciousness I can't even do to be honest. That's Leslie Scott, but not very vicious looking founder of Oxford Games. She has created more than 40 games,
像填电子表格一样有趣。它们确实完成了消除尴尬沉默的功能，而不需要每个人都去想谈话话题，但奖品与其说是赢得游戏，不如说是旅程结束了，这样你就不必再玩游戏了。而且词汇无处不在，在普通的一天里，你会使用或吸收成千上万个。那么你如何利用这些无处不在的东西并从中制造乐趣呢？顶级文字游戏的要素是什么？一点恶意，老实说我甚至做不到。那是莱斯利·斯科特，但看起来不太恶毒，牛津游戏的创始人。她创造了40多个游戏，
a lot of which are word-based, such as anagrams where you compile anagrams at speed, the children's literature game Bookworm, and the bluffing games flummoxed inspiration and ex-liberus. But she's probably best known for a non-word game, the Builder Procarious Tower out of Woodenbricks game, Jenga. I actually think a game has to be competitive, otherwise it should be called another a different occupation, I mean a different kind of pastime. There are people who completely disagree with me, there are actually companies that are set up to make cooperative games. I can't imagine it.
其中很多是基于文字的，比如快速编译变位词的变位词游戏，儿童文学游戏《书虫》，以及虚张声势游戏《困惑》、《灵感》和《前图书馆》。但她可能最出名的是一个非文字游戏，即用木砖建造摇摇欲坠塔的游戏——《积木》。我实际上认为游戏必须具有竞争性，否则它应该被称为另一种职业，我是说另一种消遣。有些人完全不同意我的观点，实际上有公司成立是为了制作合作游戏。我无法想象。
You know, I think in a funny way, Jenga is the most cooperative game that I know, but it still has an element that somebody loses. A lot of people win it, but there's one person that lose. And I think if you don't have that element to it, it becomes another pastime. It's not a game, in my opinion. So you need to bring out people's malevolence I think so, to bring the fun. I think so.
你知道，我认为有趣的是，积木是我所知道的最具合作性的游戏，但它仍然有一个有人会输的元素。很多人赢了，但有一个人输了。我认为如果你没有那个元素，它就变成了另一种消遣。在我看来，它不是游戏。所以你需要激发人们的恶意，我认为是这样，才能带来乐趣。我想是这样。
And the element of jeopardy of the possibility of becoming the worst person in the room. Yes. Several of Leslie's games involve bluffing. In Flummoxed, you have to write a definition for a word from a foreign language, and in Ex Libris, the first or last line of a famous book, and in each case, convince the other players that yours is the real one. You don't really have to know anything to play the games. You just have to be a good liar, which is fun in an etymological sense because fun originally meant a hoax or a trick and as a
还有成为房间里最糟糕的人的危险因素。是的。莱斯利的几个游戏涉及虚张声势。在《困惑》中，你必须为一个外语单词写一个定义，在《前图书馆》中，是一本名著的第一行或最后一行，在每种情况下，都要说服其他玩家你的那个是真的。玩这些游戏你真的不需要知道任何东西。你只需要是一个好的骗子，这在词源学意义上很有趣，因为“有趣”最初意味着骗局或把戏，作为一个
verb to make a fool of someone. But to goal people is fun fun too. For a little while anyway, because another crucial factor for a good game, according to Leslie, is speed. For me, yes. I love Scrabble until about halfway through the game and then it just slows down to a point where You're waiting and waiting for people to they as they sort of move their little there's seven tiles around endlessly I'm like I just get so I just get very bored by Scrabble if I'm really honest, but it's a very clever game. I Mean there's so many people that love Scrabble that Clearly that's a personal preference.
动词是愚弄某人。但愚弄人也很有趣。至少有一会儿，因为根据莱斯利的说法，好游戏的另一个关键因素是速度。对我来说，是的。我喜欢拼字游戏，直到游戏进行到一半，然后它就慢下来，直到你等待又等待人们移动他们的小东西，他们有七个瓷砖在无休止地移动，我只是变得非常无聊，如果我真的诚实的话，但这是一个非常聪明的游戏。我的意思是，有这么多人喜欢拼字游戏，显然这是一种个人偏好。
Before an anagram, I would have said that my favourite word game was Boggle, which is pretty fast. Three minutes? No messing. Pretty decisive, whether you want it or not. That's another thing. If you're stoking the competitive spirit, you don't need the additional ugliness of there being no clear indicator of victory. Boggle operates on a pretty straightforward point
在变位词之前，我会说我最喜欢的文字游戏是《Boggle》，它非常快。三分钟？不乱来。非常果断，无论你是否想要。那是另一回事。如果你在煽动竞争精神，你不需要没有明确胜利指标的额外丑陋。Boggle在一个相当直接的点上运行
system, predicated on the quantity of words and the letters they're in, but if you're supposed to be scoring on the words qualities, those are rather more complex to ascertain. Not many people realise that actually the success of Scrabble, the ultimate word game, is based on the fact that it was designed by a statistician who figured out the scoring system. I mean it was the first time somebody had sort of had a word game where you the score of the letter is based on the fact that he research absolutely incredibly thoroughly the numbers of times a particular'r ymdyn yw'r ysgwyrddol, ac yn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymd stack to start with was based on this and then the actual scoring is based on that. And it works. I mean, whether you like the actual player of the game, we have a mathematician to thank
系统，基于单词的数量和它们所在的字母，但如果你应该根据单词的质量来评分，那些就更难确定了。没多少人意识到，实际上拼字游戏的成功，终极文字游戏，是基于这样一个事实，即它是由一位统计学家设计的，他计算出了评分系统。我的意思是，这是第一次有人有了一种文字游戏，字母的分数是基于他非常彻底地研究了特定字母出现的次数，然后实际的评分是基于此。而且它有效。我的意思是，无论你是否喜欢游戏的实际玩家，我们都要感谢一位数学家
the Scrabble, which I think is not fun. Sorry, Scrabble. But a game where you can try out just by memorising every two letter word will never have my affection. Now, I don't want Leslie to think I'm casting aspersions, but words are free, and so are the car games like Ice Buy and Number Plate. So how does she get people to pay to play games like Flomoxed or Ex Libris, which you could play using books that you already have on your shelves? I mean, sure you could make yourself a chess set if you wanted to. I think it's just simply that you open a box and you sit down with your group of friends
拼字游戏，我认为那不好玩。抱歉，拼字游戏。但一个只要记住每个两个字母的单词就能尝试的游戏永远不会得到我的喜爱。现在，我不想让莱斯利认为我在诽谤，但文字是免费的，像“我看见”和“车牌”这样的汽车游戏也是免费的。那么她是如何让人们花钱玩像《困惑》或《前图书馆》这样的游戏，而你可以用书架上已有的书来玩呢？我的意思是，当然如果你愿意，你可以自己做一套国际象棋。我认为这很简单，你打开一个盒子，和你的朋友坐在一起
and you don't have to just rummage around trying to find books that are suitable that happen to be sitting on your bookshelf. And flammocks you don't need 112 dictionaries? Yes, exactly. It's exactly that. If you've just got a copy of X-Leabras, there isn't all that sort of faffing. It's there. You get on with it and you play
你不需要只是翻箱倒柜试图找到合适的书，碰巧放在你的书架上。而在《困惑》中你不需要112本字典？是的，完全正确。正是这样。如果你只有一本《前图书馆》，就不会有那种麻烦。它就在那里。你继续玩
it and more importantly with ex-leabers is that the plot summaries that we've written are actually quite carefully written. They're not just the back of the sort of stuff that you get at the back of a book. Sometimes to lead you down the wrong path, but often so that they're names that are mentioned in there so it doesn't come up as a complete surprise that you're incorporating those names into your first or last lines. That took quite a long time and because X-Leap is also, because you can play the first or the last line, it does actually sort of limit the books that you use. Not all of them have brilliant first and last lines if you're still of mean, or usable ones then. So you're paying for the curation or... Exactly, the fun.
它，更重要的是《前图书馆》的剧情摘要是我们实际上写得相当仔细的。它们不仅仅是你在书背面得到的那种东西。有时是为了引导你走上错误的道路，但通常是为了让那里提到的名字，这样你把这些名字融入你的第一行或最后一行就不会显得完全出乎意料。这花了很多时间，而且因为《前图书馆》也是，因为你可以玩第一行或最后一行，它确实限制了你使用的书。如果你是说，或者可用的，并非所有书都有精彩的第一行和最后一行。所以你是在为策划付费，或者……没错，为乐趣付费。
Actually, curations are good words, I'll use that. When you've invented your game, you need to name it. Something that indicates what's involved. The name and anagram of Tells the Story. And has a whiff of fun and hasn't already been nabbed by someone else. As the years have gone on, it's got more and more difficult to come up with a name for a game that hasn't already been used. It is quite a process and whether it's a game or not, I mean the whole process of naming
其实，策划是个好词，我会用它。当你发明了你的游戏，你需要给它命名。一些能表明涉及什么的东西。名字和变位词讲述了故事。并且有一丝乐趣，还没有被别人抢走。随着岁月的流逝，想出一个还没有被使用过的游戏名字变得越来越困难。这是一个相当大的过程，无论它是否是游戏，我的意思是命名的整个过程
a product. It's actually a part of the process that I quite like. People would like to argue that it's a science. I'm not sure that there's a science to it. But there is something in it, there is something about it that, you know, words like say Viagra. It was quite a clever word for something that does what it does, gives the sense of vitality and water flowing as a Niagara. And with games it's tricky because you do want something snappy. Like Jenga?
一个产品。这实际上是我相当喜欢的过程的一部分。人们喜欢争论这是一门科学。我不确定这是否有一门科学。但它里面确实有一些东西，它确实有一些东西，你知道，像“伟哥”这样的词。对于做它所做的事情的东西来说，这是一个相当聪明的词，给人一种活力和像尼亚加拉大瀑布一样流水的感官。对于游戏来说，这很棘手，因为你确实想要一些时髦的东西。像《积木》？
It's some Swahili. It means build. It's the imperative of the word. It's Cajenga is to build. And I gave it a Swahili name because I grew up in East Africa speaking Swahili. I thought if I gave it a name that had no meaning to anybody who didn't speak Swahili,
它是斯瓦希里语。意思是建造。它是这个词的祈使形式。Cajenga是建造。我给它起了一个斯瓦希里语名字，因为我在东非长大，说斯瓦希里语。我想如果我给它起一个对任何不说斯瓦希里语的人都没有意义的名字，
there was a chance, one day, if you said the word Jenga, people would just think of the game that I just put on the market. It's lucky that Swahili word for build was quite a short word and easy for people who don't speak Swahili to pronounce. Well, you'd think it would be easy to pronounce. I have had people telling me categorically that the game is called Yenga. Well, why would you know how you're actually... Yeah, of course.
有一天，如果你说“Jenga”这个词，人们就会想到我刚刚推向市场的游戏。幸运的是，斯瓦希里语中“建造”这个词是一个相当短的词，对于不说斯瓦希里语的人来说很容易发音。嗯，你会认为它很容易发音。我有人断然告诉我游戏叫“Yenga”。嗯，你为什么会知道你实际上……是的，当然。
That's the thing. I did put on the market myself, originally, Hasbro sort of took it on in the States. They said they loved the game, but they absolutely hated the name. And so we had a little bit of battle on our hands, and I really was almost a sort of deal breaker. I just said please because they were saying this is going to be difficult enough to sell something that nobody's ever come across anything like this and then
就是这样。我最初确实自己把它推向了市场，孩之宝在美国接手了它。他们说他们喜欢这个游戏，但他们绝对讨厌这个名字。所以我们手里有一点战斗，我真的几乎是一种交易破坏者。我只是说请，因为他们说这将很难卖掉一个没人见过类似东西的东西，然后
to have a name that's meaning this. They wanted to give you some idea of how the game was what was involved in playing the game. Like, build a stack of blocks. Yes, exactly. It's snappy little ones. Or tumbled down, I think they wanted to call it at one point, or Timber. And I was going, no, no, please don't do. I was just talking to work. But you stuck to your guns?
有一个意味着这个的名字。他们想让你对游戏是什么，玩游戏涉及什么有一个概念。比如，建造一堆积木。是的，完全正确。时髦的小东西。或者“倒塌”，我想他们一度想叫它，或者“木材”。我当时说，不，不，请不要这样做。我只是在谈论工作。但你坚持了自己的立场？
I did. And what the funny thing is now is that I think they've got very selective memories. We'll all talk about how, you know, what a great name it is. How clever they were to have stuck to that name. Difficult. Yeah.
我坚持了。有趣的是，现在我认为他们有非常选择性的记忆。我们都会谈论，你知道，这是一个多么好的名字。他们坚持那个名字是多么聪明。困难。是的。
Presumably, the blocks are easy enough to rip off, but are the rip off jenga sets allowed to be called jenga? No, no. If you come up with a name that is too descriptive, and you won't necessarily be able to trademark it, there was another side to, I think, called it Jenga, as I could trademark that name, as a consequence of that, you can't call any old stack of blocks Jenga,
据推测，积木很容易被抄袭，但抄袭的积木套装可以叫“Jenga”吗？不，不。如果你想出一个太具描述性的名字，你就不一定能注册商标，我想还有另一面，叫它“Jenga”，因为我可以注册那个名字，因此，你不能把任何旧的积木堆叫“Jenga”，
although that doesn't seem to stop people doing it. You can't officially, and Hasbro would definitely be down on you like a ton of bricks if you were selling something, calling it like a ton of bricks. I hadn't realized I'd just... So, that's it. Leslie Scott is the founder of Oxford Games, which you can find at oxfordgames.co.uk.
尽管这似乎并不能阻止人们这样做。你不能正式地，如果你卖东西，叫它“像一吨砖头”，孩之宝肯定会像一吨砖头一样压在你身上。我没意识到我只是……所以，就是这样。莱斯利·斯科特是牛津游戏的创始人，你可以在oxfordgames.co.uk找到。
I'll be playing Excliberus with some friends this weekend. I will probably be losing Excliberus to my friends this weekend, but it'll be playing X-Libris with some friends this weekend. I will probably be losing X-Libris to my friends this weekend. But it'll be fun nonetheless. Before we go our separate ways, your randomly selected word from the dictionary today is... Imagineere! Now! A person who devises a highly imaginative concept or technology, especially the attractions in Walt Disney theme parks, try using it in an email today, perhaps to Oxford dictionaries
这个周末我会和一些朋友玩《前图书馆》。这个周末我可能会输给我的朋友们，但这个周末会和一些朋友玩《前图书馆》。这个周末我可能会输给我的朋友们。但无论如何都会很有趣。在我们分道扬镳之前，你今天从字典里随机选择的词是……“梦想家”！现在！一个构思出高度富有想象力的概念或技术的人，特别是华特迪士尼主题公园的景点，试着在今天的电子邮件中使用它，也许是给牛津词典
asking when they started doing product placement. This episode was produced by me, Helen Zoltzman, thanks to Martin Orstrick for providing music and editorial advice. If you have invented any word games, I would love you to tell me about them. It's been so interesting to hear your responses to the last episode about step-family terms. Some of you have come up with some very good suggestions, I think, for alternative terms to step bonus,
询问他们什么时候开始做产品植入。这一集是由我，海伦·佐尔茨曼制作的，感谢马丁·奥斯特里克提供音乐和编辑建议。如果你发明了任何文字游戏，我很乐意你告诉我。听到你们对上一集关于继亲术语的回应非常有趣。你们中的一些人想出了一些非常好的建议，我认为，作为继亲的替代术语，
like the Danes and the Swedes use, or near-parent, or someone came up with Meta, Meta Mother. Pretty cool. Anyway, keep in touch at Twitter and Facebook slash Allusionist Show and at the Allusionist.org. That's your little taste of the Allusionist. Now go subscribe for yourself and every two weeks in your life will be better. That's 99% of visible for this week.
像丹麦人和瑞典人使用的那样，或者“准父母”，或者有人想出了“元”，元母亲。很酷。总之，在Twitter和Facebook slash Allusionist Show和Allusionist.org上保持联系。这就是你对《典故学家》的一点品味。现在去为你自己订阅，你生活中的每两周都会变得更好。这就是本周的《99%隐形》。
We are Sam Greenspan, Katie Mingle, Avery Troubleman, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7KALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of ArcSund, an architecture in interiors firm, a beautiful downtown Oakland, California. Thanks to MailChimp the Night Foundation and people just like you, we created Radio Topia from PRX, home to the illusionist and many other fine podcasts. Get to know them all at radiotopia.fm and if you have a company or project and you want to underwrite us, which is a good idea, I highly recommend it. Email sponsor at radiotopia.fm.
我们是Sam Greenspan、Katie Mingle、Avery Troubleman，还有我Roman Mars。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，由位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的一家名为ArcSund的建筑与室内设计事务所制作。感谢MailChimp、奈特基金会以及像你们一样的人，我们创建了PRX旗下的Radio Topia，这里汇集了《魔术师》以及许多其他优秀的播客。请访问radiotopia.fm了解它们。如果你有公司或项目想要赞助我们，这是一个好主意，我强烈推荐。请发送电子邮件至sponsor@radiotopia.fm。
You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. We're all on Twitter, Tumblr, Instagram, and Spotify. But right now, you can see pictures of a bright yellow castle. Really bright yellow castle at 99pi.org From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。我们在Twitter、Tumblr、Instagram和Spotify上都有账号。现在，你可以在99pi.org上看到一座亮黄色城堡的照片，真的是非常亮眼的黄色城堡。来自PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。